any fan of The Simpsons out there that's
usually the response you get I had a
hunch yeah well if you're Simpsons fans
I have some very exciting news for you
this is real
you could win a chance to have yourself
drawn into an episode of The Simpsons
not only that you can get a
one-of-a-kind drawing of your character
personally signed by Simpsons creator
Matt Groening himself this is all real
all the money raised from this contest
benefits night of too many stars that's
right it's a contest and that of too
many stars is a benefit for autism
programs nationwide which airs this
Sunday night at 8 p.m. on Comedy Central
now this chance to be in the Simpsons is
a huge event The Simpsons has never done
a contest like this in its 25-year
history now if you're curious I'm sure a
lot of you are you want the details on
entering the contest go to omae's
dot-com slash Simpsons ok this is pretty
special just think you could join the
select group of individuals who have
been Simpson eyes on the actual show
huge stars like me Conan O'Brien oh yeah
there you go
mark hamill mark hamill yeah Paul
McCartney yeah
and Steve Buscemi
anyway it's a fantastic opportunity so
check it out and good luck good luck and
it's for a great cause
[Applause]
you